Let us now study a very
important counting problem,
the problem of counting
combinations.
What is a combination?
We start with a set
of n elements.
And we're also given a
non-negative integer, k.
And we want to construct or
to choose a subset of the
original set that has
exactly k elements.
In different language, we want
to pick a combination of k
elements of the original set.
In how many ways can
this be done?
Let us introduce
some notation.
We use this notation here, which
we read as "n-choose-k,"
to denote exactly the quantity
that we want to calculate,
namely the number of subsets
of a given n-element set,
where we only count
those subsets that
have exactly k elements.
How are we going to calculate
this quantity?
Instead of proceeding directly,
we're going to
consider a somewhat different
counting problem which we're
going to approach in two
different ways, get two
different answers, compare
those answers, and by
comparing them, we're going to
get an equation, which is
going to give us in the end,
the desired number.
The alternative problem
that we're going
to use is the following.
We start, as before, with
our given set that
consists of n elements.
But instead of picking a subset,
what we want to do is
to construct a list, an
ordered sequence, that
consists of k distinct elements
taken out of the
original set.
So we think of having k
different slots, and we want
to fill each one of those slots
with one of the elements
of the original set.
In how many ways can
this be done?
Well, we want to use the
counting principle.
So we want to decompose this
problem into stages.
So what we can do is to choose
each one of the k items that
go into this list
one at a time.
We first choose an item that
goes to the first position, to
the first slot.
Having used one of the items in
that set, we're left with n
minus 1 choices for the
item that can go
into the second slot.
And we continue similarly.
When we're ready to fill the
last slot, we have already
used k minus one of the items,
which means that the number of
choices that we're going to
have at that stage is n
minus k plus 1.
At this point, it's also
useful to simplify that
expression a bit.
We observe that this is the same
as n factorial divided by
n the minus k factorial.
Why is this the case?
You can verify that this is
correct by moving the
denominator to the other side.
And when you do that, you
realize that you have the
product of all terms from n
down to n minus k plus 1.
And then you have the product of
n minus k going all the way
down to one.
And that's exactly the product,
which is the same as
n factorial.
It's a product of all integers
from n all the way down to 1.
So this was the first method
of constructing the
list that we wanted.
How about a second method?
What we can do is to first
choose k items out of the
original set, and then take
those k terms and order them
in a sequence to obtain
an ordered list.
So we construct our ordered
list in two stages.
In the first stage, how many
choices [do] we have?
That's the number of subsets
with k elements out of the
original set.
This number, we don't
know what it is.
That's what we're trying
to calculate.
But we have a symbol for it.
It's n-choose-k.
How about the second stage?
We have k elements,
and we want to
arrange them in a sequence.
That is, we want to form a
permutation of those k elements.
This is a problem that we have
already studied, and we know
that the answer is
k factorial.
According to the counting
principle, the number of ways
that this two-stage construction
can be made is
equal to the product of the
number of ways, number of
options that we have in the
first stage times the number
of options that we have
in the second stage.
So this is one answer
for the number of
possible ordered sequences.
This is another answer.
Of course, both of
them are correct.
And therefore, they
have to be equal.
And by using that equality, we
can now find a formula for
this coefficient n-choose-k
simply by taking this k
factorial factor and sending it
to the denominator of that
expression.
So by equating this expression
with that expression here, we
find the final answer, which is
that the number of choices,
n-choose-k, is equal to
this expression here.
Now, this expression
is valid only for
numbers that make sense.
So n can be any integer, any
non-negative integer.
And k, the only k's that make
sense, would be k's
from 0, 1 up to n.
You may be wondering about some
of the extreme cases of
that formula.
What does it mean for n to
be 0 or for k equal to 0?
So let us consider now some of
these extreme cases and make a
sanity check about
this formula.
So this is the formula
that we have and
that we want to check.
The first case to consider
is the extreme case of
n-choose-n.
What does that correspond to?
Out of a set with n elements,
we want to choose a subset
that has n elements.
There's not much of
a choice here.
We just have to take all of the
elements of the original
set and put them
in the subset.
So the subset is the same
as the set itself.
So we only have one
choice here.
That should be the answer.
Let's check it with
the formula.
The formula gives
us n factorial
divided by n factorial.
And then, since k is equal to n,
here we get zero factorial.
Is this correct?
Well, it becomes correct
as long as we adopt the
convention that zero factorial
is equal to 1.
We're going to adopt this
convention and keep it
throughout this course.
Let's look at another extreme
case now, the
coefficient n choose 0.
This time let us start
from the formula.
The formula tells us that this
should be n factorial divided
by 0 factorial and divided by n
factorial, since the number
k is equal to 0.
Using the convention that we
have, this is equal to 1.
So this is, again, equal to 1.
Is it the correct answer?
How many subsets of a given
set are there that have
exactly zero elements?
Well, there's only one subset
that has exactly 0 elements,
and this is the empty set.
So this explains this particular
answer and shows
that it is meaningful and
that it makes sense.
Now, let us use our
understanding of those
coefficients to solve a somewhat
harder problem.
Suppose that for some
reason, you want to
calculate this sum.
What is it going to be?
One way of approaching this
problem is to use the formula
for these coefficients,
do a lot of algebra.
And if you're really patient
and careful, eventually you
should be able to get
the right answer.
But this is very painful.
Let us think whether there's a
clever way, a shortcut, of
obtaining this answer.
Let us try to think what
this sum is all about.
This sum includes this term,
which is the number of
zero-element subsets.
This number, which is the number
of subsets that have
one element.
And we keep going all the way to
the number of subsets that
have exactly n elements.
So we're counting zero-element
subsets, one-element subsets,
all the way up to n.
So what we're counting really
is the number of all subsets
of our given set.
But this is a number that
we know what it is.
The number of subsets of
a given set with n
elements is 2 to the n.
So by thinking carefully and
interpreting the terms in this
sum, we were able to solve
this problem very fast,
something that would be
extremely tedious if we had
tried to do it algebraically.
For some practice with this
idea, why don't you pause at
this point and try to solve a
problem of a similar nature?